aujourd'hui la comédienne marie hélène
braillard et son mari edouard molinaro
nous reçoit marylène maria vous la
connaissez vous l'avez vu dans claudine
de colette edouard molinaro
c'est le réalisateur de comédie et de
satire à succès tels le téléphone rose
et la cage aux folles
maintenant vous savez succès non j'ai
rien fait je parlais avec sauramps filer
doux nom et ses débuts laïcs sont qu'une
bande passante
non mais il n'a pas à faire des bulles à
deux et pourquoi il fait des bulles ça
veut dire pas mon lapin de faire des
bulles un sous son nez il a raison si
gênant les bus n'est pas parce que nous
jouons doivent être avertis qu'il n'y a
pas une situation dramatique pigasse
faut comprendre les choses ainsi et leur
mise en valeur on l'avait prévu d'avoir
un chien jeudi avant 5 ans répond à quoi
ça ne ment pas d'un coup comme écouter
on avait très envie d'avoir un chien
mais alors moi j'avais essayé de
planifier je m'étais dit je veux qu un
oui voilà c'est à dire je me suis dit je
voudrais avoir un enfant alors je me
suis dit je vais avoir le chien 20 ans
que l'enfant pour qu'il n'y ait pas de
jaloux
et puis en définitive le destin l'aide
c'est autrement puisque pour la trouver
et on l'a trouvée avant d'avoir le temps
de la première fois que j'ai tourné avec
des animaux ça a été dur antigone de
sophocle que j'avais fait pour celio
lorenzi et puis la deuxième fois c'était
bon enfin beaucoup plus
il y avait quand même un contact
beaucoup plus agréable avec l'animal
puisque c'était une petite chatte
absolument adorable la shob grenet
oui fanchette la chape de colette la
chaîne de claudine dans ton critique
le magazine
un cliché un petit système beaucoup et
ils font semblant de ne rien savoir et
jean bury de chagrin suite raide comme
un petit chien
j'en ai de la peine regarde ma série
mademoiselle saint jean elles sont si
heureuses élues pose plus à rien tu peux
attendre est de me mettre à la buanderie
dès 6h bien si tu veux bien être la
grande année si je tendre as matelots
d'une bien tendrement j'attends d'être à
demain
les pandas patience at one us
c'est ce qu'il a vu d'autres animaux
plus bizarre dans votre vie ah oui j'ai
eu un animal très bizarre pas très comme
même est très bizarre comme animal si
vous voulez le compagnie c'est un cochon
bon oui ça plextor et qui était vraiment
comme un chien fait qu'il me suivait
partout que j'adorais gelé connu tout
petit bébé évidemment j'ai apprivoisé et
c'est très très intelligente et
cauchemar qu'est ce qui peut à bahreïn
by me suivait partout il était
complètement liberté c'était à la
campagne si vous n'êtes absolument
partout c'est un énorme il devenu un
gros monsieur il était grand monsieur
oui l'été une intelligence redoutable
extrêmement gentille maman coup ça a été
la plus grosse peine de ma vie en ce qui
concerne un animal parce que
malheureusement il est il avait été
élevé pour qu'on fasse des jambons et je
ne sais quoi
herring est fou et il a été tué
j'ai plus jamais
vous rencontrez ya peut-être plus jamais
un produit non je crois pas
numéro 1 tout dans le monde
françois perrin de hp pas une enquête
sur les grandeurs et j'aurais aimé
montrer à paris
d'accord je vous appelle au revoir pas
plus
oh
oui
je sais pas
c'est une grande première c'est la
première fois que vous avez un chien
côté c'est la première fois en tant
qu'adulte oui j'en ai eu beaucoup dans
mon enfance avec des chats aussi mais
j'avais hésité à prendre une
responsabilité d'un chien parce que
j'avais beaucoup de travail parce que
j'avais des appartements et comme depuis
suis là je n'ai pas choisi enfin celle
là plus exactement je n'ai pas choisi
c'est vraiment elle qui m'a choisi c'est
alors là oui oui elle arrive de rome
s'entraîne finir la cage aux folles
elles habitaient là bas une une petite
maison avec plein de chien plein de
chats et est plein de noyau actuel fut
venu dans cette maison et elle s'est
jetée rebonds voilà que voulait me
quitter alors le mal était dans l'avion
était la principale qualité que vous
trouvez la sâone aussi sa tendresse
extraordinaire latendresse puis cette
énorme quantité d'amour que ces animaux
là vous vous donne moi je n'avais pas
l'habitude de ça j'avais oublié ça et
dans cet appartement à que chien comment
ils allaient moeurs il commence déjà à
faire connaître son saison on broie les
chiens ils ont toujours appelé
territoire ah oui eh bien elle a un
territoire très privilégié c'est dieu
bureau des douanes est à dire que l
chaque fois tu edwards est là elle se
couche sous le bureau d'ailleurs c'est
le premier endroit
elle avait tellement peur quand elle est
arrivée dans cette maison que les deux
nations
son bureau est aussitôt s'est couché ses
pieds sous le bureau et depuis c'est
vraiment son endroit privilégié les
alors sur le plateau comment ça se passe
on ça se passe très très bien laver très
peur le premier jour j'ai pas pu la
laisser à la maison parce qu'elle
supportait pas d'être éloigné de moins
de casser tous les blocages les amener
sur le plateau et les premiers jours là
bas un peu peur parce qu'ils ont
beaucoup de monde
et puis maintenant
elle est très très heureuse elle se
couche au pied de la caméra elle regarde
les scènes et là paraît-il que quand on
est obligé de la sortir du plateau pour
pas ce que vous faites là prise alors là
elle ne vit plus là elle aime pas ça du
tout parce que quand un assistant
s'approche d'elle elle sait très bien
que c'est pour l'éloigner de moi les
bleus doivent elles un petit peu je
déroge l'arrivée j'ai cru que j'ai cru
que je n'y arrive pas familles attachées
vraiment et maintenant ça commence à
prendre une ampleur attaque mais moi je
veux dire je suis assez étonné parce que
quand on va sur les plateaux de cinéma
et les réacteurs sont pressés le temps
court vous très chers et quand on à agir
le jour l'impression qui paraît une
catastrophe a lancé par un peu une
antithèse hors des chiens sur des sur
des plateaux écoutez c'est un film dans
lequel l'atmosphère est tellement
agréable surprise hier donc j'avais pas
depuis le monde accuse jean pierre
marielle et comme les disques tellement
formidable et charmant que l'atmosphère
ici l'étendue qu'on peut se permettre ce
genre de show via du film j'aurais pas
bien que j'aurais pas me mentir c'est
une richesse en chien fou et surtout un
signal d' analyse de moeurs et caetera
et quand on voit l'importance que prend
les animaux à l'animal domestique de la
société bousculent à jour ne ferait pas
un sujet sur un thème comme ça avec un
thème animalier
j'avais je n'y ai jamais pensé avant de
connaître cette pouf là mais depuis que
je la commune de me relaxer très très
envie de te faire un portrait de cette
chose là même film à bientôt
à bientôt au revoir